thank you kendall all right time to do a
little tbt as we take a look back at
vegas history
on this week's sin city chronicles
it is time for this week's sin city
chronicles a weekly
look back at vegas history and
happenings on march 25th
2003 all eyes were on las vegas
hey i'm justin timberlake and i'm here
in the lobby of the coliseum at caesars
palace along with four thousand other
special guests
invited tonight to the opening of celine
dion's first ever theatrical show
celine dion began her first residency at
caesar's palace the opening night
was broadcast live on cbs and was hosted
by justin timberlake
celine's a new day residency ran through
2007
and she did a total of 717 shows
celine will be back in las vegas at
resorts world in late
2022. jerry tarkanian became the coach
of the unlv basketball team
on march 23 1973 tark would take unlv
to the final four for the first time
three years later
it was march 26 1977 when unlv was
eliminated by north carolina
the final score was 84-83
now one of the stars of that game was
guard reggie theis
whose jersey now hangs in the rafters at
the thomas and mack
and his daughter rocky works here at las
vegas now
[Music]
oh look at that it's the king of the
keyboards billy joel and elton john
brought their face-to-face tour to the
mgm grand on march 25th
1995. the face-to-face tour made billy
and elton one of the most successful
concert tandems
in pop music history and let's end here
march 22nd 1985 we have some good old
fun when the tractor pull came to the
thomas and mack
for the first time look at this guy go
come on keep going keep going
that's about 200 yards he pulled that
sled i tell you what nothing
beats 1980s entertainment and that's
your sin city chronicles for the last
week of march